this could be a tentacle belonging to a  giant squid in hogwarts's Black Lake the  image appears on the recently revealed  and absolutely stunning cover art for  the art and making of Hogwarts Legacy  exploring the unwritten Wizarding World  the official art book which is being  published by inside editions will  release on February 10 2023 same day as  the game and is expected to clock in at  more than 250 Pages the official  collectible will include original  concept art exclusive interviews as well  as fun facts and information about the  game making process but what exactly do  you think we see here in the bottom  right corner of the new cover art